let's look at something so
his offense
defense depends upon
his mobility to a great deal
and his mobility depends upon
his organization so
if this will consider he's standing with
a straight posture
neutral you can go backward forward
change angles and things like that
usually when he's aggressive you'll get
some sort of chance going
just like
certain organizations lead towards
certain tactical possibilities therefore
other organizations take away those
possibilities
kazushi is utilizing that premise
and we do it in a particular way in
aikido
we're going to cause a particular
disorganization
which is a tilting of the spine
a disorganization of the shoulders to
the hips
to the knees relationship reduces
mobility power
reduces offense and defense capacity
so anytime in your technique a guy is
in neutral you're
not doing kazushi so fix that
look for that so
we want to instead get that
disorganization
so if you look at the body
you can do like uh you'll have the eight
directional tilts
so nine o'clock three o'clock
four can you get the idea
i'm tilting in all the angles of the
clock
but aikido generally only uses
four which are really just two which is
really just
one okay it's following
an ancient chinese
epistemology on the nature of the
universe
so you have these numeric values
one two four so
what are the four the four
are the corners tilt to four o'clock
till to eight o'clock till to ten
o'clock
till to two o'clock what are the two
it's always going to be a tilt um
either going in and forward you see
in and forward that may be eight before
the same
or out and back out and back
are the two okay what is the one
they happen by the same exact means
okay so we have a drill and we're gonna
go over
those means all right first i'm going to
demonstrate the means
so our drill is this though and he comes
in
[Music]
i get to work on those two kazushi
patterns
so you see i'm gonna take a one
frontward inward then
the outward backward you guys see that
so back to where we were standing i
took the four o'clock and
the two o'clock we got it
why are they one because it's the same
the means in which i generate it so
there's a kind of spiraling figure eight
that happens inside my body and i'm just
reversing it
i have the other one i don't have two
ways of doing it
it's just going in so if you do it with
him
you watch my body
so you watch my body and you'll see
that i'm doing the same thing over and
over
you take away the arms you can barely
tell which
thing i'm doing okay such that
um if i stand in a different
relationship to him
i can do different things with both so i
can do
what you thought was just the front
inward i can do to the out backward
with the same exact pattern so for
example if i'm going here
this is the front inward but it's to the
outback
you see or uh
i can be do the backward one but he will
do a front
a front inward ball
do you see do you get that he didn't go
backwards he went forward
but i did it with the out backward
kazushi pattern
but it really wasn't it was the front
inward position
okay you guys understand okay so
those are going to be your geometry but
your
mechanisms or your modes of operation
they're varied okay so
let's say
i have he
he's pushing in and i'm going to
do the yield i'm going to do a yield on
that
i can do my heels externally
which by which i mean i move in space
and i use my common everyday just
musculature
so he's pushing and i move
okay
that's one way so how did he move i just
got out of the way and he fell into the
hole i created
okay another way is i
pull him in same exact kind of thing
those ways are like beginner ways okay
if you're if you're not working on the
kazushi patterns you're not doing
the geometry of the art but now you are
working on it but now the question is
how do you do it
this is external strength based
it's beginner stuff okay what we want
to get to is two modes of or two
mechanisms
one is i take an energy that can come
inward come inward and take an energy
that can go outward
okay but i don't do it through
external lead through external muscle
okay so just stay still the coming in
is going to be that ik adhesion
and the projecting now is the cool cube
so i do the same drill
and i'm going to do a cochlear
projection on the first part
so he goes then
i'm not pulling him as an
ike adhesion on the second part
so i can be learning the geometries in
the drill
but i'm not learning the modes of
operation
okay so he's going to push
i send the energy down to the ground and
then
sync with the rebound boom then
blend boom
so there's it's going to look different
it's going to look different if i just
go like this
what can i look for smaller movements
that he pushes boom
and then uh here i'm gonna find
this part is actually where i
sticking to him that i don't need the
arm
okay to get the most
operation in the beginning you have to
use your body
meaning your core meaning your torso it
it has to do the pattern you cannot do
the pattern from the shoulder
we cannot do the pattern and get either
one either one of those
my body has to move
boom
[Music]
so if you watch
body body
just like when i was doing the drill you
you see it because my body's moved
if i did the technique like this
and i now did that in the air but i took
my arm away you wouldn't see any
movement
but you did see movement because my body
is doing
okay so let's start there
let's go back to this drill and let's
see you
move your body
and as we move our body i'm going to
feel the energy of the cocky
come in so if he pushes and i hold it
here i should feel
he's just he's pushing me down and i was
making
my feet feel like
okay we sit there all day
then i come around and when i come
around i
should feel his center
in other words don't take off the
pressure
in front of his body through his body
how by moving my body then
up then here feel that
okay feel
this first adhesion going forward
then body okay
let's try that again
okay when you don't have the modes of
operation when i don't
have a project a projection capacity or
an adhesion
capacity you start to look for other
things
you'll utilize other things it's just
human nature
so then but then the technique doesn't
function
uh tactically it looks like it does but
it doesn't
okay and you have to do different things
okay so
uh in other words you have to do like
some tilts
stuff like this and you did get the tilt
but it's a yin yang world so if the
inward outward spiral
is one of those then the outward
backward spiral
is the other and both
actually happen in the aikido position
so it's not that i tilt him
as i demonstrated just giving you the
vector
but the second angle is going to come in
just so because of the vector that i
showed
and it's going to work on the other
corner so
it goes like this on the other corner
the two are hitting the body at the same
time
so i'm not tilting
i get a tilt and then his center gets
hit by the
other vote you see so
if i just tilt he looks like that
so the same thing his center now i get
the first inward kazushi
then the second one is that part
boom do you see and that again
happens where here
do you see it the only difference is my
arm is shared my arm was there
so boom i used it
in a coccu variant a young projection
but on the second part of the drill i
used it as a
yin adhesion so i'm going to make
contact with him
and when i make contact with him that's
where i turned him did you see it
i'm not going to go here and around
[Music]
not my arm
will go slow i bring my arm to here and
then i do the
body um do you see then
the throw what changes when you do it
the other way well here you become
arm-dependent
okay and that's a goofy thing to be
when you're armed dependent there's no
effect on his body
but when you go to the body
[Music]
there's effect on his body
second he's already
falling on the first part of the throw
whereas on the other one you gotta now
all you're going on the second part
that's gonna require muscle
so when i've been telling you
focus on the first part this part is
what i mean
do you understand
okay i i think uh
your your perception of the world is
is determined
or constructed through how you're
thinking
through your worldview and so if i don't
have
a projection or an adhesion mode of
operation
i not only go to cert other things other
mechanics but the patterns themselves
get warped i can't see why that
pattern would work or i can't even see
the pattern
i don't understand how i can get him to
go backwards by
by going forward is what is most common
in aikido okay instead i know how to
make someone go backwards by going
backwards
okay so if you watch my body
i'm just going to describe it generally
my body goes to the left
it comes back to the right and you all
look it makes sense
he went to the right south
and i turn south but in the yin yang
world
i should be able to have them go north
and turn
south again do you get it
so that would be to my right here we go
i'm going to do it again
right again do you see body went to the
right
what the beginner does is go well i
wanted it to go that way so we go that
way
but i don't have kazushi you think you
have pollution you don't have kazushi
and it takes a lot of muscle and you're
going to redefine what the last move is
the last move is aiming
not throwing
boom here and go right back to the right
then ball now somebody who got the right
part and you do realize that the body
did fall
you come around here you go boom and you
realize that guy's falling
and then you're over here with them okay
you still have the drill to complete so
for those people
i do go to the right boom like that
on my back into the technique don't get
don't go to sleep okay all right let's
try it again
i missed the motive operation
i come back and i have to go around and
now what did i do to my spine
i tilted it okay i did the very
disadvantage
that i was trying to do in him okay
and then he's he there was no effect on
him
so somewhere in the fight he got
stabilized
which is not good i broke the kazushi
timing
then the other mistake is now i have to
throw him
with this movement and this movement is
now outer deltoid
be strong
okay now i have a couple choices
could go well i'm going to have him i'm
going to have him closer to the outer
deltoid
but then there's no effect i just
prolonging the lack of effect as
he's inside the radius or he's outside
further out from dropping out further
out
out and now the distal end
lever concepts working against me he has
more leverage than i do
okay
so let's correct this
i go here and when i do the turn boom
do you see not here same
ball here boom there
okay and then he's falling
and i follow that i stay with him
and this hand is going down
down not out
boom boom
he's falling i haven't touched him yet
i'm inside this space let's rewind
step you're fine there and he's you go
go go into the fall i'm staying with him
you see do you see how i'm doing that
it's not it look it's not moving him
i'm blending with him boom
i'm blending with him
and in that way i get to complete the
last portion
of the drill i get to do boom
[Music]
that part which all of you tend to be
here
so one
you stop here you need to go here
so body development requires full range
of motion
in the drill you see and i end up over
here
okay try it again
okay what happens in real life
is happening here in training in real
life
in real fighting doesn't happen okay
in real life people power and real
training left people cower
once they feel the kazushi pattern
working on them
it scares them and so they try to shut
off
the mode of operation okay
so a very simple example is
when he feels that the connection here
starts to push on his center he'll break
the connection
do you see for training purposes
the training has stopped
[Music]
the drill requires that he keep
connection
in his grip that was prescribed using
the keyhole model
it's not that he's here and then he gets
to change oh my
god okay he
uh puts his center in the grip so he's
not standing here
he is boom able to project
meaning uke is practicing the same skill
that naga is there's no need for a
grouping
resting check his watch skill
okay it's the center is in there
ground is in the grip through the center
and
if he doesn't do anything i will project
him
you got it i can't do that here with
this limp arm
so i'm going you'll on the scary cat new
kids you'll feel that
it's a chance for you to develop your
own skill
even no matter where you're touching you
can find the center again
do you see but you have to change the
angle of what your hand is doing
but you don't change the motor operation
of what your body is doing
okay so you'll feel that and just come
in to the center at a different vector
then here's the other one is they'll
feel whoa
they're going to fall do you see and
they'll twist on you
okay in the same way
that i might change this vector here if
he comes around and he twists on me
i'll find his center here
can you see
but when i find his center there
still boom you see it's still in there
pop
in terms of application
usually uh the guy that
gets rid of the lever he'll have to
create a hint space
that's where your tummy comes in okay
so always have your hands ready boom
to do these things boom pop
but when he keeps his connection it's
hard for me to ever get there
do you see it's hard for me to ever get
this
his connection is not to me his
connection is
ground center grip that's what i mean
okay
i connect him through the mojo operation
kokua
key okay so
um right now we're working on this part
here
boom here a lot of the who kids are
twisting in place
okay and then you can't do the technique
so even when i hit it's not just a smack
if you pay attention you see
it's the same pattern that i'm using on
the center
so
this goes here into the movement
into the drill okay because
i don't want the kazushi to stop yes he
is hittable
when he twists but i'm not
addressing the critical functioning of
his organization
so i'm not employing kazushi i might get
one shot in
but we're not going to be exchanging
blows or continuing
on so your attempt must
follow the same kazushi rules
it must add to one of the patterns
and his center must be traversing across
space because you applied the other
pattern
in that same movement across the hip
line okay
now if you're training you're wasting 50
percent of your training time
every time you take away the drill
mechanics
so you can think of the drill as a bench
press
and you're the barbell but you're a
piece of crap barbell that keeps
going into a chain link format okay
you're not a very good barbell and only
a very advanced person can learn from
the drill
you're going to teach them a lot just
like people now lift
chains because yeah it will make you
stronger because a lot of stability is
going into the barbell
but you're wasting 50 of the mechanics
time that you have
so my mechanics is as i said when i'm
here
his body is being is utilizing those
moza
operation from a young side as naga
i'm doing it from the inside as uke
at any point you could see that
can turn it into a young side which i
can't do when i'm in here
when it's no not the connection of
ground center
contact point he's doing ground center
contact point
so the kind of golden rule is the more
projectible
i become the more i can't project
so if i do in my uk like this i don't
i'm not projectable
skilled people will project me but
beginners will not capitalize upon the
drill
and i definitely will not be projecting
anyone either
i don't know what to feel okay so i'm
gonna
again ground go ahead ground
center grip and you can see that moves
me when he goes in to cook you
fill the hole and not go ahead
no do you see that's i'm starting to
twist i'm starting to disengage from the
connection of ground center grip i don't
have my grip
anymore okay and then he goes and i go
like i'm sitting here keep your
your grip lock your center
boom he'll turn me do you see i don't
have to do it
i just maintain that connection between
ground center
grip and if he did his thing he's going
to be just fine
it's a little off isn't it we get a
little more penetration we'll do it
again
and go forward forward
and do it again i'm making myself
projectible keeping my connection
forward you're going around me
i see how much you're around me try to
throw me i'm going forward
go slower boom wait
wait wait this goes forward
into my body into me there you go there
boom
okay so stop twisting disengaging as you
get
if they are you're the senpai use it to
your advantage to refine your skills
okay because your art is immature
you're spiritually immature so
you tend to focus on surface superficial
tactile visible things but
as i said this whole thing is happening
inside my body
um and it doesn't
have to be an actual movement
and so the harder he the harder he
pushes like he's really driving
you can get it without any apparent
movement do you understand
did you see okay it's not that i'm here
and i'm
imagining it i'm not imagining it i
i am doing it i am doing it okay
i am doing it doing it
he's making up the energy equation that
side that's off at the beginning the
beginning
he's just providing
the required energy feed but aggression
makes
everything allowed to be smaller
becomes more effective but when i can't
do it
then aggression makes it all fall apart
faster easier
okay so uh
we're gonna do the same drill
he's he's gonna be striking he's gonna
give weight here
do you see and i'm going to do the same
drill
here we get even caught tighter
okay and you can see my body
is doing the same thing
it's not just laying he's not just uh
touching me
he's giving me pressure you see well i
take it into the ground and then do the
same movement in the same connection
make sure you're close enough because if
he's out more
then you as you can are still doing hand
stuff
they come in you get your whole body you
could you could just think of it as he's
he's grappling do you see he's grappling
and i'm gonna do the same
don't make the same confusion of trying
to move his arm that's not what i'm
doing
i'm going to move his body my body
goes into his body
and here you can see where the throw
actually happens
it happens on the going forward
so again close he's driving you're gonna
get tired okay especially if your
your dog is doing it at this slow pace
okay let's try it so we go back to this
this the two patterns are in the one
pattern okay so yes yes he's gone this
way
but as i said his hip is going
the other way okay
you're not he's not doing a somersault
in my head
the hip's not going in the same
direction as the head
do you understand this is why this
center
uh doesn't just tilt it's not real
position
his center boom traverses
do you understand okay so the same thing
here
we're close close and he's gotta be
pressured i'm not just tilting him
his his center has to move you see
it comes back won't his center is
traversing
can you see that
again if all i have is external
then he will just kill he'll just tilt
from kind of doing a turn and move like
that and then
come back okay uh you have to
uh measure for the center traversing you
cannot forget that same thing so
it has to project through boom it has to
project through do you get it it has to
traverse across space
otherwise it's not real position okay
okay since one is two two is four four
is two
two is one you don't have
different ways of addressing anything
so uh when he does his
kesa his yoco man boom i don't have a
new
technique it's not gonna be oh this one
i go in my arms okay
it's gonna be so yesterday we were doing
uh this one
do you see remember
so it's not like whoa and he makes this
big giant strike that allows me to go up
he's tight he's tight boom
he's trying to knock me out so
i'm here well when i feel it i do the
ikyo yield to expose the face
i'm just going to take part of that
kazushi patterns
in the drill not the whole thing
how much so i'm here
just enough to get his head to tilt that
was it
that's all i needed then the other
aspect
take over the same front inward position
so we're tighter here
i'm not impacting him
whoa pop
i'm not up here
with any kind of anything different
so we're going to go slow because
there's a lot of crap on the map
not starting a million miles away so if
the guy started out there and his hand
went up i'd kick him
he's got to be in that sweet spot where
i won't create distance
i won't use a longer range weapon
okay and that i have to go in and engage
and you should know that's the same
sweet spot for your strikes
in other words when you throw a strike
from out there you should tactically
know i
ain't never get in there okay you have
to get yourself
and this is where the drill starts okay
he does the technique i'm here that was
it
[Music]
so in the last drill
i was using it as a young
yawn you see projection
a coq projection start it again here
and boom in this one
i'm using it same pattern but in a yin
perspective
but you can see it's the same pattern
you see just i find the center
then i maintain zero pressure on the
center
so boom that was
[Music]
and now they their spiritual maturity
causes the young class when he goes
fast and you go into your hair like that
no
and yield boom that was it
all right let's try okay so we're again
we're back to he look how he's just
standing there
so his body move is moving
even when it comes through it's coming
through
it's not that i move and he got to keep
his balance
that's what a lot of you are doing i
have some of you that are just staying
staying here and then your arm fighting
and
he's just standing and then i have some
of you that are using that
okay i'm i'm in stay
stay stay where you're at stay where
you're at i'm gonna do this same drill
can you see it can you see it okay
do you see so here is
the same pattern i'm in his center
in a young version okay i'm here
well i'm going to do it in the yin
version which means it is an adhesion
so as i do this do you see
his aggression i already started the
disorganization of his body do you see
the tilt in his shoulder
that's going to make him fall into the
hole
that means his center is going to
traverse as well as his spine tilting
i'm not standing here and i do this
maneuver
he's standing straight up and then all
of a sudden i have
super strength and i bend over a guy
okay so
let's slow it down again
and you're going to do it in a young
version so boom this is just like the
standing version of the seated drill
but then after that you're going to do
it in the yin version so
it's it's this that i feel that's my
adhesion point
it's not me moving out of the way and he
falls in okay
this adhesion
different
can you see that if he hits there
go it does go that way but then what are
you noticing
it's going down
so and there it is
on the other way
[Music]
there it is then it continues it
so first drill young version
second drill same pattern but it's mode
of
operation is different
[Music]
okay let's try it again so normally
you you have this idea that you're going
to
enter you're going to enter behind him
because the techniques weren't taught to
you that way
that's not that's not it you start a
spiraling geometry
using one of these kazushi patterns okay
and he will turn to fight you once once
he gets on the spiral
and that's where your ten con becomes
viable
but the edemi is
about two to four inches
and it happens in amidst the spiral
so if i'm doing this
wrong i'm going to have to take a big
step
so i go here and then i'm going to get a
big step to get in the back
but if i'm doing this right
you can think of it in two ways and i'm
mentioning these two ways you can
understand the distinction
he's gonna i'm gonna pass this strike
or his body through the strike into the
other hand so i'm doing the pattern
boom you see he's
he's hitting the other hand
and i'm here
it's not me he's staying there and you
see i have to reach for it up
i have to reach for it
or i move out of the way and i have to
reach for it again
he's hitting the other hand so we're
engaged in here
and i'm hitting okay just like i wanted
to keep striking
so the other thing you'll see if i could
hit the head if i'm making him run into
me
whoa look i'm there
i got there so the other way to think of
it is
i'm not only passing his head to me i'm
passing his
shoulder right the shikaku
to me so i'm here like that
i do the drill oh and it's two to four
inches
and i'm where the other person had to
take
foot two feet step
so make that part of this drill where
there's the pressure
again the young version
the inversion and you're here
here get it there this is not it
it's there pass it to you
pass it pass it
past it
or hit or just do the technique
okay let's try it again if you don't
have the motor operation you have to
reinterpret
everything and you do something it
doesn't it doesn't work
so uh what you're doing is a call it a
yield it's a
lee based yield it's external so he goes
to strike and you go like that
you see but your posture is the one
being compromised
you're getting that getting out of the
way i'm not fast enough
he hit it i made contact and now i'm
gonna do it so
i actually don't go that way do you see
that
that's that's not what we're doing look
at my body
and you guys see he can just walk in why
wouldn't he be able to walk in he's
athletic
he just walks in so maybe i got out of
the way that move but i'm no better off
i'm actually worse off
so watch that movement
huh
is that it no that's not it
this was it look at the pattern
not this way this way first
[Music]
but
so not this way
the other way so
[Music]
push hard hard hard yeah
there
okay let's go so we have the drill
on and we're outward backward
nothing changes inward
you know how backward is this one
on your yokomin uh
response can you see it okay we're just
working on the front inward
so the throw has to be coordinated with
the kazushi pattern that i'm generating
so as i pass pass
the head does not go here the head goes
here
so that my projection angle can cut
across the hip
so i'm not lowering him
and then he is accelerated and he
doesn't want to face plans so he rolls
that's not what we do here okay so
move this goes here his base gets
deconstructed
which means i have to bring the head
around so he goes
up head comes around
okay let's go this
point is going to be very subtle
okay again if i don't understand the
modes of operation i don't understand
ikea i don't understand coke you i can't
hit here i can't project
i have to make up for that absence with
external things then tactics change
to fit that model okay
i want to show you what is different a
size from when you do
these external things you actually are
doing
the strategy that we're trying to do to
him if you disorganize yourself
okay but
you're doing a keyhole and so he has to
start with a prescription okay
obviously he doesn't he doesn't strike
it's the same thing okay but we slowed
it down
with just a constant pressure okay
that's what we're doing all right so
once i do the movement i get here
do you see where i'm at okay
watch watch what i'm gonna ask again
okay
uh can you go forward
do you think okay but now watch watch
what happens
can you go backwards did you see his
balance got taken
okay so he can't
he can't go forward because i didn't do
a
yield like you guys an external leap
based heal
there's a ground vector here so he can't
go forward
okay so push forward and he'll be
projected out
he's pushed into the ground and there's
the kokyu
is inside the ikea adhesion so
he's going to push hard and he gets
displaced it's no different than we're
here
and he pushes push hard and he gets
displaced do you understand
so he's here and
it's that cool cue inside the ik
adhesion
that starts the rotation okay
but at the same time if he pulls out
then the ik adhesion will take little
continuous disorganization
okay so i'm here like this right
and you're gonna go well he was gonna
try to regain his fun
though no no he's not do you see that
he's going to lose his balance as he
tries to regain his balance this is what
you don't have by a lead based
yielding okay so as i go
i'm moving this whole thing don't don't
uh don't bend over okay
do you see how i'm doing that i'm moving
to the bottom
okay it's not it's not
shove that down as at the contact point
i'm moving his body
with the adhesion with the adhesion so
i do the whole thing with the adhesion
so as as he tries to regain his balance
it just takes his balance more away do
you see that
all right now here we are again same
thing
if you try i i have an adhesion here and
it looks like i'm pushing down
but i have another adhesion here so as
he tries to lift up
he gets traversed it's not that i'm
holding them down go try to let that
see the difference the strength
he tries to lift up he's going to make
his center move
so he tries to come into me and he can't
come he can't come in
because the cloak coqueus in the center
of the ik adhesion
okay so when i'm here like that and he
doesn't want to
go in the throw let's even have you put
your leg back down
okay he doesn't want to go and throw it
doesn't matter
you still don't go in the throat dude
okay it's still going through his body
do you feel that so when i ask you guys
to
resist the throw everyone can resist the
throat because you're all doing external
yields
you can't get him together if you're
doing the
the actual modes of operation you're
it's not that i'm stronger than him it's
just that i'm constantly affecting his
balance constantly affecting his balance
okay same thing here
i'm not stronger than him i'm not
stronger than him i just create this
relationship
do you see creating that relationship
creating that relationship
creating that relationship resist
okay try
you understand your role now all right
so but it doesn't start there okay
there you go elbow starts to drop
right and i don't go this way you see it
comes off
okay elbow starts to drop pressure
and i'm going to go here there's the
tilt that's all i need okay now here
this is going to be not off feel off
on and you're going to see push into me
push hard there you go
okay pull from me you see
you see okay what you did in those two
times
is you disconnected your center so push
good that's it and pull
good watch what's happening
you see not here
go ahead and pull not that
together pull here
you see so not fighting here
so you see grip no grip
pull okay
now when you go down you went off you
see
keep it on keep it on one
pull
they're down now you went off again and
you're attacking
we line a little bit
right here still
on on not pull
turn casing
just a puzzle just the puzzle
pass connection move the body
get the geometry project across
okay so even if you're pulling out
you don't still function therefore
it's not a momentum technique you
understand
it's not me getting out of the way they
run so fast they lose their balance
that they take a role voluntarily which
we found when i asked you don't take the
role if you don't have to
no one except for ronans
who guess were taking the role okay
try it again